la vida vuelve a las calles de rangún
mientras los residentes se abastecen de
comida en un mercado local con poca
presencia militar a la vista los bancos
han abierto y las conexiones telefónicas
e internet han vuelto aunque la
incertidumbre está en el aire este
taxista no ha tenido un solo cliente en
todo el día
edward hará a fumar incluso durante la
pandemia mis ganancias no han sufrido
gran impacto pero ahora las cosas han
dado un giro repentino con la situación
política actual la gente tiene miedo a
salir del lugar y muestra cara hago esta
ruta al aeropuerto internacional de la
ciudad ha sido cerrada por los militares
que parecen tener el control firme desde
el golpe del lunes el ejército ya ha
reemplazado a 11 ministros y diputados y
ha declarado el estado de emergencia el
paradero de la ley de mianmar aún
sanssouci no está claro fuentes de su
partido liga nacional para la democracia
dicen que está bajo arresto domiciliario
en su residencia oficial mientras tanto
se tiene entendido que cientos de
parlamentarios están recluidos en
viviendas gubernamentales de la capital
para la ong human rights watch las
acciones del ejército son
golpe para la transición del país
el gran temor ahora es por supuesto que
todas las personas que hablaron en
contra de los militares a lo largo de
los años durante la democracia tengan
que esconderse porque podrían enfrentar
represalias
el golpe se produce después de que el
ejército se negara a aceptar los
resultados de las elecciones de
noviembre que dieron al partido de aung
san suu si una victoria aplastante el
ejército la acusó de fraude algo que fue
negado por la comisión electoral del
país